hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
were back on monster in the world again
and today we're gonna be talking about
cool to Rothen and specific how to get
the highest pursuit level and reward
level for her as quick as you possibly
can so electively if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I covered hips
and guides like this type of stuff I
also cover solo guides for most of the
monsters I even have one on cool dropped
it isn't a solo guy but it is still a
guide for her as well which I will
actually leave in the top right if you
click the I if you do want to check that
out since this is a cool tour out the
video you can go to that if you're
having a little bit of trouble fighting
her what else to do solo guide videos
talking about monsters like nerd grant
eighty Ostra bajas awk all those types
of monsters I have videos on those and
as well on how to do the event quest on
which ones that you should be doing in
specific and then which ones give you
the best rewards and stuff like that
so with that out of the way let's get
started so as I stated today we're gonna
be back with cool to Roth's and she has
been re-released back into Monster on
her for the second time so far I've done
lots of thinking and decided to do a
video I'm gonna get the highest pursuit
level and reward level first we're going
to be talking about the pursuit level
then go to the reward level and then do
a general recap at the end so first off
further pursuit level you want to be
collecting as many footprints and chips
that she leaves behind as much as
possible walk behind her and you can
usually collect their footprints when
she walks by but when her parts of
Brooklyn should we usually drop a
scattered gold chip which looks like
this on screen
both the footprint and the scattered
gold chip will give you 10 points
towards your pursuit level as well as
giving you 10 research points sadly
though the boulders do not count towards
the pursuit level you can obviously
still use these to get the extra
research points and use them to knock
out cool to Roth to potentially cheer
for horns but they do not sadly
contribute to the pursuit level but just
to recap these aren't really that hard
basically follow her around and collect
her footprints or if you happen to be
fighting her and she leaves to go to
another area while she leaves pick up
the chips and footprints you couldn't
grab because we're fighting her and you
couldn't find them then continue to
fight her and rinse and repeat and all
that stuff on top of that those little
crab guys as well that you see crawling
around cool to Roth's footprints and
chips and materials also give pursuit
points they only do give two points but
it's still worth noting now obviously
the pursuit level is a little bit easier
to do and really doesn't take them much
effort but for the reward level you're
going to be doing a little bit more
thinking and a lot and it's a lot harder
compared to the pursuit level to do
basically what you have to do is
complete the objectives I have
shown in the clip right now these have
different values depending on the
difficulty for example breaking a part
of cool to Roth like her four leg or
whatever that happens to be is a lot
easier than breaking off her horns hence
why the horns are the most valuable in
terms of points you can get as many as
you want or as little as you want it
doesn't really matter you don't have to
get all of them to get the max level you
can still leave a few outs and don't
worry about struggling to do every
single thing on the checklist but the
more you get the higher the rewards are
going to be deep for example in the
video shown I believe I was level 12 for
the reward level and the most I got for
completing it was about a couple silver
weapons but when I ran through with a
team and defeated her and did all the
good stuff
I got max rewards and I got three golds
out of it but this is a 16-man siege
other people not in your group but in
your gathering hub or session you can
also break these parts and they will
give you partial points some of these
will be half the actual value like 10
points instead of 20 or some could be
different values like breaking the tail
in your game could give you 120 points
but if another group does it in their
game you get 25 points it is still
contributing to your reward level it's
just a lower value on screen you're
going to be seeing what those values
actually look like when you get one it's
a bright yellow banner that comes up on
the on the right of your screen
but when a other team or other group in
your session does it it's more of a
lighter faded yellow that comes up as to
know what to differentiate of whether
you did it or they did it just so you
know what to look for when you're
playing in terms of breaking off one of
her parts such as her chest or four leg
gold plating is basically whack at
whatever part doesn't look chipped until
it breaks after enough damage you'll see
white scrapes meaning that it's close to
being broken so keep hitting it it
doesn't really matter what weapon you
used to break the set body part but I do
see a lot of people using heavy hitting
weapons like hammers and great swords
probably to KO the monster and then
long-range weapons usually stick wood
slicing ammo or personally for me I use
a long sword for the fight I can break
parts just fine so obviously it's
entirely up to you on what you want to
do just try to join a team member if
he's hitting an unbroken part so you can
break it quicker with the two of you but
on top of that I'm also going to be
covering each area that you fight her in
as so you can look for an advantage as
well as breaking parts and completing
those objectives a lot quicker so on
screen you're going to be seeing an in
depth map made by Cora Meno
on reddit I'm hopefully I said that
correctly I will leave a link to the
original post down below if you want to
see the picture a lot better but this is
for the first area and the numbers on
screen are where the cannons are in the
purple dots on screen are where the
boulders are located as to get a better
understanding of where to be at during
the first phase and what to look out for
the second area there isn't really much
except a few wedge beetles which you can
use to mount cool to Roth with the third
area has three stalactites on the
ceiling which you can use to puncture
her with basically this will absolutely
ko her allowing you to do more damage to
her horns if they're not chipped or
break any body parts off if necessary
and the last area has this little thing
in the middle that you can jump off of
to mount her as well and if you missed
the first one or if you want to get a
second mount within the match you can do
that as well just make sure to run up it
and then jump into it your guy will
climb up jump off of it and then you can
do one of those in mid-air attacks and
hopefully mount her using that like I
said in the beginning we're gonna do a
little bit of a quick recap to catch
everybody up for the pursuit level once
again you basically want to follow her a
run and grab her footprints as she walks
and for the chips after you break off
parts of her armor she'll be dropping
those randomly so when she's done when
you're done fighting her and she goes to
a different area just collect that and
then continue on to the next area and
then of course for the reward level you
want to be completing the objectives as
much as possible you don't have to do
all of them but you do have to do
majority of them to at least get max
rewards so basically the easiest thing
to do is just start breaking parts of
her chest or body or any of that type of
stuff off so basically join a teammate
while she's down and just wail at her
stomach or anything that doesn't look
unchipped
off or unbroken as to break it and then
get the points for it but that's going
to be then as video today guys thank you
guys for watching the video like the
video few if you did enjoy subscribe if
you're new I cover solo guides for most
of the higher tier monsters like the
Elder Dragons and stuff like that as
well as I also have a guide for Costa
Roth which will be at the end of this
video if you do want to check that out
like I've also stated I cover tips and
tricks and guides and stuff like that
like this video and as well as I covered
the weekly event quest so that everybody
knows what to do and how to keep up to
date and all that type of stuff and what
type of new goodies they add in the
event quest my two most recent videos
are gonna be on screen if you guys do
want to check that out and with that
guys I hope you agree yesterday thank
you for watching the video and peace out